Speaker 1: Maybe my favorite moment from the
entire State of the Union yesterday was when
Senator Mitt Romney, a Republican, had a conversation
with lying Republican Congressman George Santos.
It was seemingly tense after the fact.
Mitt Romney was asked, what was that all about?
And Romney says, I told Santos, you don't
belong here.
Romney Listen, not not a guy I voted for in
2012, but good for him for saying this to
Jorge Santos.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: Why did you just say you don't
belong here?
Yeah, Why?
Why do you say that?
I didn't expect that he'd be standing there
trying to shake hands with every senator in
the United States.
That's a given.
Given the fact that he's under ethics investigation,
he should be sitting in the back row and staying
quiet, parading in front of the president
and then people coming into the room.
Do people respond to you?
Speaker 1: By the way, I have to tell you,
many elected officials in these situations,
they walk super fast and it makes the reporters
have to sprint and blah, blah, blah.
Look at Romney respectfully walking slowly
in order to allow the reporters to do their
job.
You got to commend the guy for it, he said.
Speaker 2: He says he you know, that he embellished
his record.
Look, embellishing is saying you've got an
aide when he had an A-minus.
Language is saying, you mean you graduated
from college, you didn't even attend and he
shouldn't be in Congress.
And they're going to go through the process
and hopefully get him out and but he shouldn't
be there.
And if he had any shame at all.
Speaker 1: He wouldn't be there.
Right.
To make a point to say that, though, I mean,
even.
Speaker 2: I mean.
Speaker 1: It is kind of out of your way that
he was.
Speaker 2: Standing right there in the aisle
shaking hands with everybody.
Did he respond to you?
He may have.
I didn't hear him say that.
Speaker 1: Man, this is just absolutely the
best.
And John Boy did a sort of attempt at lip
reading what went on.
Let's just listen to a little bit of it.
I would have given a lot to be sitting right
there between the two of these guys.
Speaker 4: My Twitter just absolutely blew
up from his lip deliberating.
So I'll try and dive into it a little bit.
Everyone kind of figured out what what Romney's
saying.
He comes in on the bottom, right.
He says, you ought to be embarrassed.
You ought to be embarrassed.
Ought to be embarrassed.
You got to be embarrassed.
You got to be insane.
And he's just saying I should be.
I should be.
And then I don't know what he says here.
I actually don't know what a Romney says it
looks like.
Speaker 1: Anyway.
So then they go back and force forth looking
at this like it's the Zapruder film.
Good for Mitt Romney.
I don't have much other commentary other than
good for Mitt Romney.
We've got to keep the pressure up on George
Anthony.
Santos divulged or some people wrote to me
and said, you shouldn't include Katara because
there's really nothing lying about being a
drag queen, although he did lie about whether
he was a drag queen.
But you maybe don't include guitar.
So anyway, George Anthony Devil there, Santos,
he shouldn't be there.
And we've got to keep the pressure up so that
he maybe will resign.
I think the window may be closing on that,
but absolutely.
Nice job by Mitt Romney.
So big picture, Joe Biden, good speech triggering
Republicans overtly.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders, disgusting response
and Mitt Romney.
Best sort of, I guess we would call it ancillary
moment at the event.
And we will have all of these clips for you
on our Instagram at The David Pakman Show
and on our YouTube channel at YouTube.com
slash The David
Pakman Show.